- [Jason] How's CES going for you?
- It's going super well.
This is the only public thing I'm doing,
I've literally been in
hotel rooms having meetings
trying to make some fuckin
money the whole time so.
Just meeting with clients mainly,
a couple of emerging platforms,
but very focused on, you
know what's interesting
CES, South by, Cannes, these big events
I never go to the stage, I
don't consume the content.
I'm even speaking less, I just am using
a ton of the opportunity
to have the meetings
that I need to have over the next 120 days
in one place.
So basically, I come
to Vegas for three days
to save five or six days of travel
in the net score, so just
trying to be efficient.
- I think everybody's curious what
somebody like you who
is touching all points,
who makes a mission out
of connecting with people
and making sure that you know what's hot,
what's new, what people
are thinking about.
What kind of conversations
are you having here,
what are you seeing, or
who are you meeting with
that you're really excited about
what kind of technologies are you seeing
that you're really excited about.
- I think what's very unique about CES
is that people get very
excited about what's coming
so I'm always a big fan of,
I know some of you here follow my content,
I'm very big on day trading attention.
What that really means is
I like being practical.
I don't like when people
think I'm a futurist
or a disruptor.
I don't think I am.
I actually think all I am
is just very practical.
I try to pay attention
to what you're paying
attention to at scale right now,
and how do I bring you
value in those environments.
So the thing that's interesting to me here
is everyone's talking
about, you know, voice
and IoT and connected
this, connected that.
Which is absolutely gonna to happen,
I'm super excited about it.
I can't wait to never
leave my fuckin room,
like it's all going to be great.
But for me I think it clouds a lot,
I would say the far
majority of companies here
will go out of business before the promise
of what they're trying to deliver on
becomes consumer at scale.
And so for me, I'm excited but tempered
in trying to help people stay
alive for the holy grail.
There's a lot of people in 2007
that thought social media
was going to be big.
The difference between
me and a lot of them
was I knew how to stay
alive, from 2007 to 2013
before it became really real.
And, you know, for me that's what CES
always reminds me, which is great,
I can't wait to have my robot wipe my ass,
but before that happens make sure
that you're still in business in 2027.
And so there's a little bit too much 2027
talk for me, but at the flip side
I love that people are inspired,
excited, meeting new
people, bouncing ideas,
thinking about things differently
and I would argue, for everybody
I'm looking at right now,
if you see something that allows you
to then use that as a
proxy to be practical
over the next 24 months,
that to me is interesting
in the way I think about CES.
- Yeah, so where you were going
there was where I wanted to pick up
because you have an easy situation
in that everybody wants
to come and talk to you.
That is not the case for most people here
who are trying to grab attention,
who are trying to find
connections, it's a lot harder.
What is your advice to
folks who have to go
out there and pursue
instead of being pursued?
- I'm a big fan of giving advice
I've actually taken myself,
like I'm a big fan of
eating my own dog food.
I used to come to events like this
and nobody knew who the hell I was,
that I was in the wine business
and it made no sense for me to be here.
I'm an extrovert, it's comfortable
for me to do what I
recommend these people,
which is if you literally
don't know each other
it's probably a good idea to say hello.
You've got a common point of view
of where the world's going.
As many people as there are here,
it's still a very tiny
percentage of the net score.
So for me it was comfortable to come
to something like this, listen to people,
and say hello, grab a business card,
send an email, try to
build a relationship.
I'm a big believer in serendipity,
I didn't chase the people on stage,
I knew equally that the person sitting
right next to me in a 13-year macro
might be valuable to me.
And so my advice to everybody who's not
being chased down and
cameras and all this,
is to say hello to the person next to them
because that's how life actually works.
Now, there's a lot of
people here that are shy.
You know, I grew up with
parents that had an accent.
This is an international show.
There's a million things that I can run
through my mind from the psychology of why
every person here now
won't look to the person
to the left and right and say hello.
It still doesn't make the advice wrong.
That is the ROI.
My friends, everything you've seen here
you could watch on the
fuckin internet next week.
The ROI of coming to this thing
is to engage with the people
next to you right this second.
There's nothing I'm going to say right now
that you haven't heard
me say in some other
version for the last fuckin decade.
- And you've got to remember that
everybody's here to meet people.
That's a funny thing is like,
- [Nick] Yes, but.
Go ahead please.
- You're afraid of reaching out,
but you want to connect and you have
to remember that the other people
are thinking the exact same thing.
When you ask people why do you come
to something like this, why do you go
to some conference, the answer is always
to meet other people.
That's always the number one thing,
it's not to like watch
some people on stage,
unless it's you, but otherwise
it's to meet the people who are there.
- Yeah, I mean in South By Southwest 2007
Mark Zuckerberg asked me to introduce him
to Kevin Rose, the founder of Digg.
The world changes, and so, you know,
the people that get to
sit on the big stage,
things like this, that,
the other, they change.
But you have access to everybody,
I mean there's fuckin hundreds
of thousands of people here.
I'm just a very big fan of
saying hello versus pitching.
I wrote a book called
Jab, Jab, Jab, Right Hook
because I really wanted to establish
the way I think of it,
which is I just think
that Herb and Greg should know each other.
I don't think that Greg should
pitch Herb his business.
I think they should just say hello
and create context, and then
something may come from that.
And I just believe in that.
I don't know what else to tell you.
I think it's very practical.
- Let's talk some technology
- Greg, say hi to Herb.
- (laughs) Greg, Herb, Marco and the guy
whose tag is, Robert,
now you know each other.
Oh, you already know each other.
Alright, well whatever.
So Gary, VaynerMedia's got a
division called VaynerSmart.
- [Gary] Yes.
- Where you are using new technologies,
AR, VR, Internet of
Things, to connect brands
with consumers.
Talk to me about being
on that cutting edge
how you stay on it.
- I got very focused on IoT,
products like literally your beer
reordering itself for
you, smart refrigerator
being more important than anything.
But the reality is VaynerSmart
was named three years
ago when I started it
and the promise didn't come true,
meaning it's not moving
as fast as I want it to,
thought it might, so now what VaynerSmart
does, really, is an obnoxious amount
of Alexa Skills and Google Home Skills
and even podcast marketing which is very
basic, that could be in media.
Because voice has become very real.
I'm spending an enormous amount of time
thinking about that, and
so VaynerSmart itself
is probably going to get rebranded
because it's encompassing
with AR and machine learning.
I'm starting to realize okay, the things
that I know are going to
happen in a 10 year macro,
but I don't know exactly when and how
it's going to pop.
I need to create a division where it's
highly not profitable,
because I'm just investing
and so VaynerSmart and some of the ML
and AI and AR stuff is there,
and then stuff that's even further out
like VR consumer or some
of the connected stuff
we're seeing here, that will just sit
in my investing world
and networking world,
not as an official department.
- Diagnose the problem, was it because
it's hard to move an
organization at the speed
that technology is changing?
- No, the technology hasn't delivered
on the promise of its speed.
I don't know one fucking consumer product
that's reordered itself for itself
for anybody in this home.
Like, it's always about,
my mistakes in my career
are always timing,
always.
I understand consumer behavior so well
that it's been my calling card.
I really know that everybody's gonna
do a lot of things here.
Like online dating was obvious.
You know, I didn't
think it was weird dudes
in their basements.
I thought it was going to be Tinder,
and I invested in Yobongo
and One and Highlight
and everything, I got unlucky that Tinder
was incubated inside of IAC.
I knew that was gonna happen,
everybody here is going
to be very deep in IoT
and voice and order their
toothpaste while they're,
it's all happening, it's not the tech,
the technology, so much
of the promise here,
is going to be four to six years later
than they said when they
talked to you at the booth.
So we move fast as fuck cause
I'm willing to lose money.
The technology wasn't fast.
- So how do you stay,
are you trying to plan out
to the four to six years when something
that is talked about
now is actually going to
- Always
- be enacted.
- Yeah, I lost a fortune last
year on voice strategists
cause I could taste that
it was going to be now.
Right, and whether it was 2018 scopes,
which I've signed with clients, or 2019,
I knew it wasn't going to be 2020.
I can't say that for a lot
of the technology we see here.
So for me I'm not scared if I think
it's really close within
a year, year and a half.
Look, I bought cryptocurrency in 2014
but it wasn't because, I didn't know when
or how and I didn't even know if,
I really didn't, I just knew maybe,
or kinda, or probably, or why it could.
And when you play,
when you look at the world that,
look, I think the fundamental separation
that I have is really
predicated on two things.
I have empathy, so I'm thinking about
what you're thinking
about, and number two,
I don't care about
money in the short term.
If you really actually
understand what I just
said on those two things,
if you're actually
consumer centric and you don't need money
in the short term, you always
look like a fuckin genius.
- Do you have a checklist in your head
when you see a new
technology that you're like,
that this is actually going to come.
How do you analyze something and say,
this is something I'm going to see now,
this is something I'm going
to see four to six years,
this is something I'm going to see never.
- Is this something that Sally and Rick
that know dickshit about technology
are going to be interested in?
And that it's completely
a subjective call.
And then that's number one,
but the way I answer number one
is will this save somebody time?
I missed Uber early but I got in early
because I realized very quickly,
after I didn't realize it,
that they were selling
time, not transportation.
The reason connected
devices and IoT's gonna work
is it's going to save you time.
You don't want to go to
Duane Reade to buy Band-Aids.
- And sometimes I think people confuse
convenience with time, you know?
- [Nick] Yeah.
- I feel like I see things, I think
I see some things here
or I see some things
elsewhere where it might be a better way
to do something, but it's going
to take the same amount of time to do it.
- Well I mean look,
that's what's happening
with e-Commerce, right?
Are you saving time by
spending all of January
shipping shit back?
You know, like, you've got
to look at these things
it's a super fascinating game.
I think that's right.
You also have to think about things
that are nice to haves versus necessities.
Uber, again, just as a proxy
you've got to get to places.
That is a must.
Right?
A nice to have is a million
other things we could debate.
Look, I think the barber
shop will be disrupted.
Like for the most part, not for everybody,
but you gotta get your hair cut, right?
You know, I'm coming don't worry.
I think about that.
If people definitely do
that often, scheduled,
all of that stuff will be disrupted,
but most of all it's I don't like people
and I don't like companies and businesses
that are ideological.
Like there's way too many enthusiasts here
that would like to see this shit happen.
I don't like to anything to happen,
I just want to try to figure out
what I think is going to happen.
And a lot of times that's put me
in a place where people judged me
and made fun of me, until they didn't.
All my friends made
fun of me that I signed
a K-Swiss sneaker deal,
cause I had the audacity
to think it would work,
until it all sold out
in four hours, and then
they stopped laughing.
And the reason it worked was cause I
understood where attention sat, right?
And that's how I think about the world.
- When something works you're a genius
and when it doesn't work you're a fool.
- Success has unlimited fathers,
now everybody thinks they were involved,
like Babin thinks he's the reason
the K-Swiss sneakers sold, right?
But failure has none, right?
Yeah, I mean look, but
that's what makes it fun.
If you're in a place
where you're comfortable
with accepting your losses, I'm proud
to say up here that I've had to pivot
VaynerSmart cause the timing of IoT
hasn't worked in the way
that I thought it would.
That's comfortable to me.
- It means you're watching the market.
- Yeah, to me that's comfortable.
I am so sad that so many
of you don't do things
because you're worried about being judged.
It makes me sad, like that
sucks, fuck, you know?
To me, that's my loss, like what's
that got to do with you, like I don't
give a shit what you think, Marco.
I'm doing my thing and so when you start
getting comfortable
with losing in the micro
well then you can really
start doing things
and so me that's why it's
comfortable to day trade.
If you day trade, you're
going to miss a lot,
you just have to make more than you miss.
And for me, I just am
comfortable in that mentality.
- When brands come to you, how comfortable
are they with this ride, how comfortable
are they with you putting them in touch
with something that may not be ready or
- I don't sell things that are not ready
We didn't sell any IoT.
Only maybe strategy of like educating them
on where it potentially could go.
- So then let me ask the flip,
do they want things because it's buzzy
even though you know
it's not going to work?
- Sometimes, but I don't let them
unless they prove to me that the headline
in TechCrunch or AdAge has a viable
business reason other than
them getting promoted.
By the way, not that they listen to me.
Like, client services sucks shit,
like most of my client, I mean 90, 100%
of my clients don't do what
I think they should do.
100%
But that's why I use my
personality as an outlet
for me creatively, the
Gary Vee thing is far more
a test bed for me, I'm far more proud
of being the architect of making myself
a personality or awareness, than I am
that I'm it.
Like, that's more my
parents and my environment.
They get the credit
for me being a good guy
and having charisma, that's not me.
I'm the architect of how I got you
to know who I was.
- In our story we put this
guy on the cover in June,
the story about you focused
quite a lot, actually,
on that division between
the personal brand
and the brand and it
was interesting to me.
I didn't realize the degree to which
you wanted those to feel separate.
- Yeah, I mean look, I don't want to be
a charlatan or a motivational speaker,
those aren't interesting to me.
But I'm also willing to people to judge me
and misunderstand me because I know
how this all plays out at the end.
So you can boo me in the second quarter,
I'll talk to you after the game.
- And I like the way that
you think of yourself
as an R&D lab, that's
what you, you're testing
things on yourself that you
think are going to pay out.
- Yeah, I mean like I didn't invest
in Facebook and Twitter
and Uber and Snapchat
and buy cryptocurrency in 2014
and launch an e-commerce
site in 1996 by accident.
I didn't create a brand that allowed me
to sign a sneaker deal bigger than 99%
of athletes by accident.
None of this is fuckin accident.
This is me being willing to eat shit,
and have humility and
take negative feedback
while I try to figure shit out.
I work.
I do shit.
Like while everybody's
debating, I'm doing it.
And I'm willing to take micro losses
for macro wins and most people aren't
because they want short term money
or they actually value
other people's opinions
over their own.
- On the subject of
negativity towards technology.
- [Gary] Yes.
- This is slightly selfish that I'm going
to pivot into this, but
I think it's apropos
for the setting.
So I have this podcast
called Pessimists Archive,
a history of unfounded
fears of technology,
where we look at things that
why people feared and banned stuff
that today we think of as totally normal.
Gary, I know you're familiar with it
and I love that you are also passionate
about calling out when people say
that something, that some new technology's
going to change us in some
terrible, fundamental way.
I mean, the number of
things that are going
to come out of this show that then
people are going to talk
about for six months
and it's going to ruin
the way that we converse,
it's going to ruin the
way that we are as humans
and I wonder, from your perspective,
how you address that conversation
when people say, "This technology"
"it's fundamentally bad."
- I don't agree with them.
Go Google the kaleidoscope.
Kids had something in front of them
and it was going to ruin their,
you know this, you have the account,
we tripped into that
when we were hanging out,
we are lying on this.
My level of respect for Sean Parker
and Chamath, professionally, cause I don't
know them super well, is extraordinary.
It's extraordinary, I
grew up during that era.
They're brilliant.
I completely disagree with their current
headline grabbing
statements about Facebook.
Technology is exposing
who we actually are,
it's not changing who we are.
We're struggling to deal with the fact
that we have a lot of shortcomings
that we've been able to hide before,
in our personality traits,
not "Facebook changed me."
Guys, people like, oh everybody shows
their best life on Instagram
and everything's perfect,
that's what we always did.
We just had a coffee with our friend
and said everything was fucking great.
Technology is exposing who we actually are
and demonizing technology of the moment
is always, always historically incorrect.
- Yeah, I totally agree.
I feel like, the way I think of it
is that the shape of things change,
but the thing doesn't change.
- I have no interest in listening
to billionaires that
made billions on products
then shit on those products,
cause they're altruistic.
I just don't.
I just don't agree.
By the way, I may end up being wrong.
It's all on fuckin film.
I just have a funny feeling I won't.
- Well we survived many before.
- Are you kidding me?
Like, fuckin everything
was supposed to kill,
Mike Tyson's Punch-Out!! was supposed
to ruin my fuckin life.
- That's right
The bicycle, the car, the Walkman
- It's the same shit.
- [Jason] People banned the Walkman
- Like oh, now you're stuck in your stream
on social, but it was way better
for you to watch television
for nine hours a day
and have three old white
guys tell you what to think.
Like, we're being so naive, this is about,
my friends, life is about choices.
Either we have the collective voices.
I laugh about Facebook.
Facebook doesn't make me watch
Russian hackers' content.
Me engaging with the things that are put
on Facebook show me
Russian hacker content.
You want to see how
Facebook vigs everything.
You know what nobody
uses, Facebook search.
You want to see how
Facebook actually works
before we demonize Facebook.
Go to Facebook search
right now, type in hockey.
Go like 17 pieces of content that show up
and watch fuckin hockey content
get shoved down your fuckin throat
over the next two months.
Facebook's not penetrating you
and changing your mind, there's no
fuckin Russian hacker that got you.
You fuckin actually thought those things,
you just don't like it.
- Amen.
- It's truth.
And we just don't want to deal.
We want to blame everybody
but our fuckin selves.
We have zero fuckin accountability.
You have subconscious
bias, deal with it, period.
Sorry, but it's the fuckin truth
it's not fuckin Facebook's fault
that you're a fuckin racist.
- You can take those photos of people
who are all sitting in a group
looking at a phone
- It's truth, like why are
we not having the real.
By the way, on a serious macro I'm pumped.
I actually think this is our societal
step backwards for two steps forward.
Like this is painful,
we're all dealing with it,
it doesn't feel great,
it's negativity at scale.
Like I suffocate in
negativity so the macro's
like, "Fuck, this sucks", but this
is one big step backwards, ten years,
by the way this doesn't stop over a day.
But we are going to take
massive steps forward
because of this, because the truth
is always the best conversation.
And let me remind you
who was hiding the truth,
the traditional media
companies, not Facebook.
So fuck you guys.
Like, I'm so pissed at that.
That is such lack of accountability
and then people posturing
after they made their money,
fuck you.
- Wait, I want you to expand more on that,
traditional media
companies hiding the truth.
- Matt Lauer got away with it because
of NBC and ABC and the
Wall Street Journal,
not because of Facebook and Twitter.
The internet is now the
media company, period.
Which means everybody has an at bat.
There's the commerce
and branding side of it,
which I love, like I'd
still be in New Jersey
with a bunch of liquor
stores if the Internet
didn't come along.
There's a lot of that,
when you could literally
call Rupert Murdoch
and be like, "Yo bro,
you've got some reporter"
"at Fox that's investigating me"
"like shut that shit down",
and they did, that's how the world worked.
That's not how it works anymore.
That's the bottom line.
So that's what I mean, like you decide
what the fuck's in Entrepreneur magazine.
- I do.
It doesn't mean I decide
who is an entrepreneur.
- That's for sure, but guess what,
you kinda do, because
what I mean by that is,
and we all do that, it's just
that we can all do that now.
Like every single person here can use the,
distribution has been commoditized.
I, as a personality, as a human,
has as much of an
Entrepreneur, like audience,
as now media companies.
I mean, that's absurd.
That is unbelievable transformative.
- And it's not just that
but then media companies
come to you because they
want to reach your audience.
- 100%, and it works back and forth.
It's leverage of attention.
I'm just so happy that
the truth has momentum,
and look, it's going to
change us tremendously
because not one of us, including me,
doesn't have human shortcomings,
and we're going to need to reconcile that.
The era of hypocrisy is in trouble.
We're gonna eat shit,
have a lot of casualties,
but then our grandkids are going to live
in a world where we accept
each other's shortcomings
way more than we do now,
because nobody's going to be able to hide.
Ten years ago, a lot more people
went to the strip clubs last night.
Now, with media
everywhere, a lot of people
rethought their decisions last night.
The world's changed, that's just real.
That's just the truth.
So I think that's fascinating, I think
that plays out in a
million different ways.
- I don't know that
you'll even have an answer
to it, but just to play the other side
- Yes
- Anything concern you?
What do you see that concerns you?
- Nothing.
I'm being serious, let me tell you why.
I like data, here's my punchline.
We human beings have done
a really good fuckin job
adjusting along the way.
You know what's way scarier
than Russian hackers?
The Black Plague.
I don't know, like fuckin
concentration camps
seem a hell of a lot
scarier to me contextually
than naked selfies.
- So here's what's scary,
we forget how terrible that shit was.
Right?
- That's how it gets repeated
- That's right.
We forget that we had those fears.
We forget that we fought the battles.
- There's people literally mad that people
gave them skim milk instead of almond milk
in this audience right now.
Like do you understand
how fucked up shit is?
Like we have zero perspective,
a good friend of mine,
who knows me super well,
last night at a dinner, or two nights ago,
said to me, was acting weird with me.
And we got into a little conversation
and he was kind of
razzing me subconsciously
that I only put out positive content
and that it's a facade.
And this is like, if any of you said that
I'd be like, "Oh, I totally
get it, let me explain."
But this is somebody that fairly knows me
for like a decade, I was
at his wedding, right?
I don't go to a lot of weddings,
for context, so like tight.
And it was fascinating
to me, I was like wow,
people are uncomfortable with people
that have really, like
my mom is the same way,
like I just have unbelievably
deep perspective,
which is the following,
unless the eight people
that I love the most
are really sick,
everything else means dick.
I mean that, Maria.
I'm in a struggle to lose money today,
or somebody said I was a,
you know, when AdAge said
the what the fuck moment was
my sneaker and razzed me.
That means nothing.
So what scares me as a collective?
Nothing.
In the micro, the health and well-being
of the people I love the most.
Everything else is controllable,
everything else is my fault.
- You know, something we have in common
is that we're both in positions,
to build off of what you just said,
we're both in positions of positivity.
I feel very fortunate about it
because inside me, I don't
know about inside you,
but inside me I've got a lot of enthusiasm
and positivity, I've also
got a lot of deep skepticism.
But I know that what people want from me
is positivity, that's valuable to them.
And so, it puts me in that place
where I can feel that the most,
where I can exude that the most
and I think you're probably experiencing
something similar
- You know what's funny?
I have come to finally realize
that I realize that I mean nothing,
which then doesn't allow me to have
the audacity to be cynical or skeptical.
You know?
I'm empathetic, and by the way,
parents having sex at the right moment
giving me DNA, like this is not me,
but I'm like, "Why am I not skeptical?"
"Why am I not cynical?"
Oh, because what the fuck does my opinion
mean in that for, like
the amount of people
dropping their two cents on social media
to shit on somebody,
like they mean something.
People try to build the
biggest building in town
by tearing everybody else's building down.
When you have enough talent to just build
the biggest building, you just
build the biggest building.
I could give a fuck about anybody else,
I'm doing me, and honestly, I wish all
of you the best, and I even
weirdly hope you beat me
cause that will keep me hungry.
But the truth is, I'm not worried
about other people's shit.
We're counting everybody
else's points too much.
Worry about your own shit.
- So we got a few minutes left
and let's do it by building people up,
if we're just talking about that,
- Great.
- So we had a guy,
had a conversation with Samsung folks here
just before you came on
where they were asking me,
Samsung's looking to partner
with barrier redefining people,
really amazing entrepreneurs
who are pushing boundaries
and I said, you know who they should ask,
they should ask you,
and actually fuck that,
why don't I just ask you on
stage, put you on the spot,
who should we all be really excited about?
- So one of the things that I,
you know it's funny you
asked me that question
off of what I just said,
I'm spending almost zero
time paying attention
to anybody else, so I struggle with this.
And then the only answers I know
are people that are
really within my circle.
So, I hate this question cause my head
goes to a funny couple places, right?
Rachel Tipograph.
But I invested in her company,
so it feels self serving
so I hate to, I never give the answer,
but the only reason I know is cause I sit
on the board and I watch her navigate
and I think shes's a ninja,
and an incredible entrepreneur, right?
I think she's special.
So like, the answer is the names I know
are like 20 people, all
who are self-serving,
so outside of Rachel I
won't name any of them,
but it's the ones that I can actually
see what they're actually doing.
And there's a lot of people
doing incredible stuff,
a ton of people.
As you can tell I'm very passionate
about the shit I know,
I get really quiet when I don't know
and the truth is I really don't know.
I really don't know, I'm not
paying attention to that.
I spend 100% of my time
on consumer behavior,
I care about what you're gonna do,
I obsess over it, I spend
18 hours a day over it.
I try to find out why
eight-year-old girls make slime.
I try to find out why Champion
went from being a private label at Walmart
to the brand that has the
most swag in the streets.
I try to think about what Cardi B did.
I try to think about,
you know, what's going on
on Youtube Kids and like why is Siri
every six-year-old's best friend?
I am like, that's what I spend my time on.
You're amazing at knowing their answer,
that's what you guys spend your time on.
So I suck shit at 98% of things,
it's in that 2% that I'm
going to be all time.
- But your answer actually
brings us full circle
to the beginning of our conversation,
which is about meeting
people and discovering
how great they are,
because your answer is,
well the people that I know I've gotten
to understand what their strengths are,
what their genius is,
and so the answer is go expand,
I mean, to everybody here, right,
but to everybody, you
go expand your network
and then you understand
the great resources
in people that you have around you.
- I think so, and, you know,
I think it's interesting,
there's a lot of variables to why somebody
gets put on a pedestal,
and I'm, listen, I am massively benefiting
from having a lot of sizzle,
but the only way to win long term
is to have the steak,
and I'm always trying to be thoughtful of,
like, and I think sizzle's special,
like I don't downplay, like oh you,
to have sizzle means something,
and it's, by the way, most
of the people you know.
To say who's a great entrepreneur,
it's somebody that I think is going
to be sitting there, you know, look,
guys we've lived now through
literally almost nine years
of complete global economic growth.
Shit has been great.
Like, when I look at
everybody under 30 in here,
and I'm like, oh my God, never
in their professional life have they hit
a tremendous recession or
a massive market crash.
It's so fun, like I'm looking around like
I would say 65, 70% of
everybody's faces I see here
didn't even live through
2008, let alone 2001,
let alone the mid 90s.
It's super easy right now.
There's so much money in the system.
All these entrepreneur startup people
that everybody looks up to,
they lose money every month.
It doesn't take a hero to
lose money every month.
Everybody here can lose money every month.
I've run businesses for
22 years of my life,
every day of my life,
and I've never, ever,
ever raised any capital,
and I've made money every single year.
Like, that's a skillset, so that's
what a great entrepreneur is to me,
not riding a golden era and was able
to raise capital, she or he.
No, running a business.
Now, that bubble will burst
and then we'll get to
see who's still around
and then we'll see everybody else
who says entrepreneur in their Instagram
profile right now, when they're working
in Bank of America in 24 months.
And so that's what I'm waiting for.
I'm most excited for, and waiting for,
and hoping for complete
global economic carnage.
So that we can weed out
the B and C and D players.
- Well Jesus, if you had stopped talking
a minute ago we would
have ended on a high note,
but instead we ended on that.
- I don't think, by the way,
that's where I think this is so fun.
I think that is a high note.
It's the same way I'm looking
at what's happening now.
The truth should win.
If you're a piece of
shit, you should lose.
If you're not a good entrepreneur,
you should have a job.
Merit and the truth are always
the winners in the macro.
We're just in a micro right now,
and people are confused.
- Everyone you have your mission,
introduce yourselves to each other
and give it up for Gary.
(audience applauds)
- Thanks guys.
(relaxed music)